we start with that breaking news then
and the rmt union has announced that
it's suspended a series of strikes that
threatened to bring much of the rail
network to a halt after receiving a new
payoffer so industrial action That was
supposed to begin tomorrow and also take
place on Monday and Wednesday has been
called off with union bosses saying
they're entering intensive talks with
employers as part of a dispute about pay
and conditions so the rmt's general
secretary Mick Lynch said that the
threats of strike action and our
strongly supported industrial campaign
has made the rail employers see sense he
goes on to say we have always wanted to
secure a negotiated settlement and that
is what we will continue to push for in
this next phase of intensive talks he
says our priority is our members and
we're working towards securing a deal on
job security a decent pay rise and good
working conditions our re ballot Remains
live and if we have to take strike
action during the next six months to
secure a deal we will
well Tim shoveler's Network rails Chief
negotiator said um that it's welcome the
news and that the rmt has called offic
strikes and uh the very late notice
means that services for tomorrow cannot
be reinstated and will remain extremely
limited and while we and our train
company Partners will work without pools
over the weekend there will be limited
ability to change the strike timetable
for Monday Our advice remains to please
check travel before you head out and
that remains on Saturday and Monday and
only travel by rail if absolutely
necessary he says we look forward to
getting
a background the table with all of our
trade unions early next week to see if
the progress made this week can be built
on and a resolution found so uh yeah
still limited services for travelers
next week